- Les noeuvres chinoises
complétées avaient pour but
d'entraîleleles militaires
à imposer un blocus autour
de Taïwan.
"La réunification est
inévitable, lance ce
porte-parole, c'est l'aspiration
de tout eueueuple chinois."
(tirs)
Pendanttetetemps, la défense
nationale taïwanaise organise
ses propres exercices simulant
la défense de l'île contre
une invasion chinoise qui
déilililiserait toute la région.
C'est ce qu'on redoute depuis
longtemps, à Tokyo, et encore
plus depuis que cinq missiles
balistiques chinois onrmrmrminé
leur course dans les eaux
du territoire économique
japonais la semaine dernière :
être entraîné dans
une guerre.
ANTOINE BONDAZ, chercheur,
fondation recherche stratégique
- S'il y avait une intervention
militairéréréricaine,
les troupes américaines les plus
proches de Taïwan ne se trouvent
pas à Hawaï ou à Guam,
elles se trouvent au Japon,
otototamment à Okinawa.
Et donc, une intervention
militaire américaine
nécessiterait la mobilisation
des troupes américaines basées
au Japon, et donc, de fait,
une participation directe
ou indirecte du Japon.
- Les élus japonais ont
d'ailleurs simula a a fin
de semaine dernière, une cellule
de crise, afin de répondre
à une invasion de Taïwan.
La grande crainte est que
la Chine pe e e y installer
des bases militaires
à proximité du Japon.
ROBERT DUJARRIC, co-dir. Études
asiatiques, Temple Univ. Japan
- Ceaiaiait la démonstration du
fait que la Chine peut éliminer
un État indépendant, indépendant
de facto, de la région.
Et donc, la question que se
poseraient les Japonais, c'est :
Est-ce que ça pourrait arriver
plus tard en C d d du Sud?
Est-ce que le Japon pourrait
être victime? Pour eux,
ce serait le début d'une
restructuration internationale
dans lgigigion qui serait
profondément néfaste au Japon.
- Le Japon ne cesse
de développer son arsenal
militaire. Avant même
l'accroissement des tensions
diplomatiques la semaine
dernière, Tokyo envisageait
de doubler le budget
de la défense.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Taipe